e.t is the only show to talk to the
leading ladies of the new comedy
hacks on hbo max and when you see gene
smart let's just say
well her role feels a little bit
familiar eat your heart out celine
your character has like this strange
likeness uh to joan rivers
well i met her 30 plus years ago
she definitely paved the way everyone
thinks their kids are so beautiful
impossible look at you
there's lots of joan rivers vibes in
hacks gene plays deborah vance a
legendary comedienne with a diva
attitude
my accountant didn't even know what to
put on my tax return so he just wrote
mouthy broad
the 10 episode comedy premieres today on
hbo max caitlin olsen from it's always
sunny in philadelphia is gene's tv
daughter
while newcomer hannah einbinder plays
the young comedy writer gene hires to
freshen up her
act deborah vance is intrigued by the
idea of you writing jokes for her the
qvc
muumuu lady they're caftans let me ask
you hannah i heard a rumor that you got
your sag
card on this project is that true it yes
that's amazing i found out very late
that this was hannah's first show i was
like what
truly you guys like the only reason it
makes sense that i was able to
like do this for my first time is
because i was doing it with you
that was good you know i also asked gene
if we could ever see a
reboot of her iconic show designing
women say yes
oh cool not really you know she said
since part of the court cast
has passed away like dixie carter and
meshach taylor it just wouldn't be right
i get what she's saying i still would
like to see the ladies together
but i do understand julia sugarbaker was
everything okay
[Music]
everything